Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today,
and I'm gonna tell you don't aspire
to fluency in the language you're
learning, and I'm gonna tell you why.
You'll notice by the way that I removed
my, uh, backdrop with a fake bookshelf.
Uh, people were complaining, uh,
that, uh, I never seen to take any of
those books down from the bookshelf,
and it was creased and whatnot.
So I decided to try a different look.
Tell me what you think.
Anyway, why do I say
don't aspire to fluency?
This kinda came to me after reading
Atomic Habits, and I have in the
past said, you know, we should try to
become fluent if, uh, we're climbing
a mountain, if our goal isn't to reach
to the peak of the mountain, that we're
certainly never gonna get there, that
you should have these lofty goals.
However, reading Atomic Habits made
me realize the important thing is
not to have some lofty goal but
rather, how are we gonna get there?
So the focus should not be on imagining
yourself speaking fluently, although
that's, it's not a bad thing to
do, but it's not gonna help you.
The, the main focus has to
be on what am I going to do
every day to improve every day?
Because in fact, working on a language,
as I've talked about in a variety of my
videos, can be a bit of a lonely journey.
We can have the impression that
we're putting a lot of effort
in and not getting anywhere.
And yeah, maybe the sense that one day
I will be fluent is, um, helpful to us.
But what is more helpful is to have
that sense that every day that I'm doing
something, I am improving and even to have
activities that give you small victories.
So I have enjoyed, for example,
doing these matching pairs and
assembling sentences on LingQ.
Uh, you know, it slows me down in terms
of acquiring more vocabulary is time
that is not spent on massively, you know,
ingesting the language, listening and
reading, getting my brain used to it.
But it is diving into the nuts
and bolts of the language.
It's giving me a small sense of
achievement because those are
essentially easy tasks to do.
So we get an easy sense of achievement.
It keeps me going.
I'm focused on the now, what
I'm doing now to improve in the
language, what I'm doing now to get
a sense of success in the language.
Uh, another thing could be seeking
out an opportunity to use the
language with a native speaker,
maybe who lives in your community.
uh, maybe getting on a
online lesson with a tutor.
All those little things that
keep you moving along, uh, it's
fine to have that lofty goal.
Uh, a number of the languages
that I say that I speak, in
fact, I don't speak fluently.
Uh, I can maybe get them up to fluent
at some point, but that doesn't mean I
haven't enjoyed trying to learn them.
I haven't enjoyed every step along the
way, and I will enjoy going back to them.
And so the fact that I didn't
achieve fluency, In Greek or
Romanian or Czech or Korean even.
Although I'm fairly well along,
I have a lot of vocabulary, a
high degree of comprehension,
but I can't claim to be fluent.
Fluent to me is B2.
The vast majority of language
learners never reach B2.
Okay?
So therefore, all those people
haven't been wasting their time.
All those people, myself included,
for the bulk of my languages, we've
been doing something very rewarding
uh, enabling us to discover another
language, to get interested in the
people, in the culture behind the
language, to have small victories
when we're able to use the language.
All of those things are
tremendously positive.
So if the only criterion of success in
language learning is to become fluent,
most language learners are failures,
and I don't believe they are failiures.
I don't consider myself a
failure in those languages that
I don't speak fluency fluently.
It's been tremendously award rewarding,
discovering those languages and
learning about those countries.
And I do things every day that give
me satisfaction in the language.
Even though I am a long way from
fluency, I may never achieve fluency in
Persian or Arabic or Turkish or Greek.
However, whatever I have learned in
those languages is something that I
have and no one can take away from me.
As Lomb Kato, the famous Hungarian
polyglot once said, A language
is one of those things that is
worth learning, even imperfectly.
And I think that's a very important
context to have as we study.
Think of it as something very
valuable, worthwhile doing.
You can continue to improve.
You will get as far as
you can in the language.
The longer you stay with it,
the better you will get, the
closer you'll get to fluency, but
you may never achieve fluency.
And still it will have
been a worthwhile journey.
And that's why I say, you know,
in learning languages, I shouldn't
say don't aspire to fluency, but
don't be fixated with fluency.
There you have it.
Thank you for listening.
Bye.